[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to embark on a journey to
unveil a hidden Trove of characters
whose Rich stories were left Untold on
the Silver Screen now as Avid readers we
all know that the movies could never
capture every Inked detail found within
the Beloved books so today we're going
to dive into the Forgotten pages and
reveal the diverse tapestry of
characters that were included in the
novels but omitted from the movies
ranging from minor to Major today I want
to introduce to you a comprehensive list
of the characters who for varying
reasons never made it to the big screen
I certainly hope that we will get a
chance to see some of these characters
in the upcoming Harry Potter TV show
let's dive in peeves the polter gist was
a source of mischief and laughter in the
Harry Potter books his misbehavior kept
both students and teachers on their toes
entertaining readers with his
unpredictable escapades more than just a
minor character peeves played a critical
role in the books imbuing Hogwarts with
a sense of Whimsy and liveliness
unfortunately peeves failed to make an
appearance in the Harry Potter films
with his absence leaving a void in the
Cinematic portrayal of Hogwarts
interestingly the role of peeves was
actually filled by actor Rick M however
all of his scenes were cut from the
final film it's never really been
properly explained why this happened
Even Rick M was confused Charlie Weasley
was the dragon loving Weasley sibling
who worked as a dragon Keeper in Romania
Charlie's familiarity and expertise with
magical creatures proved to be a
valuable asset to Harry and his friends
in their Quest West to Vanquish
Voldemort despite his character playing
an essential role in the books Charlie's
presence was limited to Mere mentions in
the Harry Potter films leaving us
yearning for more of his adventurous
spirit and perspectives on magical
creatures Ludo bagman was a famous
quidditch player and head of the
Department of magical games and sports
at the ministry of magic he played a key
role in organizing the 1994 quiddit
World Cup and the try was a tournament
tasks however he later became involved
in controversy due to his alleged
involvement in illegal activities and
pensioned for gambling Alice and Frank
Longbottom parents of Neville were Brave
auras who fought against vort and his
Death Eaters their Fates subjected to
the cruciatus curse brought greater
depth and poignancy to Neville's
character through their tragic story the
challenges of war and sacrifice were
brought to light despite their
importance to the story and Neville's
character Arc Alice and Frank did not
appear in the Harry Potter films denying
us the chance to feel their impact on
Neville's Journey winky served as the
faithful hous self to the Crouch family
that is until she was dismissed by Mr
Crouch after she was caught holding a
wand under suspicious
circumstances after being dismissed she
struggled with her Newfound friend
Freedom drank heavily and became
homeless before being helped by Dobby
Winky's character highlights the complex
relationship between house elves and
their masters in The Wizarding World
marolo gaun the patriarch of one of the
most noturus visiting families played a
significant role in the books through
his connection to Lord Voldemort he was
Voldemort's grandfather as one of the
last surviving Heirs of Salazar sutherin
Maru held immense PR pride in his
family's pure blood Heritage however
Mar's character was absent from the
Harry Potter films depriving us of
deeper insights into Voldemort's
ancestry and the roots of his
Prejudice merport Voldemort's mother
brought a tale of Love loss and the
destructive power of dark magic to the
Harry Potter books Mar's love for Tom
Riddle senior and the subsequent
decisions she made deeply impacted the
series Central villain however marp
significance remained unexplored in the
Harry Potter films leaving audiences
unaware of the pivotal role she played
in shaping Voldemort's path to Darkness
morphing G Mar's brother and maru's Son
added another layer of darkness and
history to the gaunt family he was known
for his aggression towards Muggles and
his ability to speak parcel tongue
Morphin was wrongly accused of crimes
committed by Voldemort leading to his
imprisonment in aaban where he
ultimately died Ted Tonks was a
muggleborn wizard who married and dreda
black together they had a daughter
nidora Ted served as a symbol of unity
and resistance in the Harry Potter books
known for his kind inclusive and loving
nature he defied the discriminatory
practices of Voldemort's regime
showcasing unwavering courage and
support for the Order of the Phoenix 's
grandson Teddy Lupin was named after him
Andromeda Tonks previously Andromeda
black was the sister of Bellatrix of
strange and Narcissa Malfoy Andromeda is
known for defying her family's pure
blood ideology by marrying a muggleborn
wizard her courage to follow her heart
and break free from the constraints of
tradition showcased the power of love
and acceptance in The Wizarding World
unfortunately andromeda's character was
very much abs ENT from the films which
is particularly weird as they showed
both of her sisters Dennis creevy was
the enthusiastic younger brother of
Colin cravy Dennis like his brother
adored Harry Potter and sought to
emulate his heroic actions he was a
symbol of the resilience and
determination of the younger generation
during the dark times of Voldemort's
rise vinas black was a former Headmaster
of Hogwarts and member of the in inous
black family who was featured in a
portrait that hung in the headmaster's
office his portrait at Hogwarts played a
significant role in the series as it
provided communication between the
current Headmaster and members of the
Order of the
Phoenix austa Longbottom Neville's
formidable grandmother was a powerful
and respected figure in the Wizarding
World her strict demeanor masked a deep
love for Neville and a driving force
behind his eventual rise to bravery
austa played a significant role in
shaping Neville's character instilling
in him a sense of Duty and
determination regrettably Augusta's
character didn't make it onto the Silver
Screen depriving us of witnessing her
pivotal role in shaping one of the
series's most courageous Heroes carcass
served as the G or chief of the Giants
he was first encountered by Hagrid and
Madame Maxim in 1995
and was later given magical gifts by
Dumbledore tragically carcus was killed
2 Days Later by fellow giant
goath Teddy Lupin was the son of Reis
Lupin and nador Tonks as a metamorph
megus Teddy has the ability to change
his appearance at will just like his
mother following the death of his
parents during the Battle of Hogwarts
Teddy was raised by his grandmother
Andromeda Tonks Teddy's character
represents the next generation of
witches and wizards carrying on the
legacy of their parents and their fight
against Darkness Professor bins was a
ghostly figure and eternally droning
fixture of Hogwart School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry Professor bins taught
History of Magic a subject notorious for
inducing sleepiness among students while
his monotonous lectures were a running
joke in the books his absence from the
Harry Potter films meant missing out on
the comical moments and insights into
hogwart's past maretta edcom is a minor
character in the Harry Potter series
introduced in Harry Potter and the Order
of the Phoenix she is a member of
Dumbledore's Army who ultimately betrays
the group to Professor Umbridge leading
to Harry and other members receiving
detention in the films Marietta is
absent and Dumbo's Army is instead Ed by
Cho Chang appears pus is a minor
character in the Harry Potter series
known for his association with Dudley
dley and his gang of bullies beer is
first introduced in Harry Potter and the
philosopher stone as a schoolmate of
Dudley's he frequently joins Dudley in
taunting and bullying Harry Potter and
his presence serves as a constant
reminder of the challenges Harry faces
in his muggle life Zachariah Smith a
fellow student at Hogwarts and member of
Hufflepuff house made occasional
appearance es throughout the series
often seen as boastful and cowardly
zachariah's character highlighted the
varying personalities and attitudes
within hogwart's student body Bane was a
centur that resided in the Forbidden
Forest he initially views humans with
suspicion particularly those who are not
respectful of Nature and magical
creatures Bane's character exhibits a
deep connection with the natural world
and a disdain for the interference of
humans
he initially opposes the idea of Harry
Potter and his friends venturing into
the Forbidden Forest but eventually
assist them in the Battle of Hogwarts
realizing the importance of their
mission hebba Smith was an eccentric and
Wealthy collector of rare magical
artifacts her character played a vital
role in uncovering the secrets
surrounding Voldemort's HW cruxes as a
descendant of Helga Hufflepuff HEPA
possessed significant artifacts
including the locket and the C both of
which became important Haw rers
ultimately Voldemort killed hepah to
create his cup HW crugs Barty Crouch
Jr's mother unnamed in the books is a
complex character in the Harry Potter
series she is portrayed as a deeply
devoted and fiercely protective mother
despite her son's involvement in the
dark arts and his subsequent
imprisonment in aaban she remains a
devoted mother her unwavering love for
her son blinds her to the truth and she
resorts to Extreme Measures to try and
free him while her actions and
motivations are misguided her character
represents the length a mother would go
to protect and defend her child even in
the face of overwhelming evidence B's
mother is omitted from the films as is
most of his Rich backstory Miriam Stout
was a Healer in the Janus thicky Ward at
St Mongo's Hospital for Magical maladies
and injuries
the Janus thicky Ward is a closed
long-term Ward for patients with
permanent spell damage Miriam Stout was
described as motherly looking and quite
chatty treating patients in the same
ward such as gilderoy lockheart
affectionately regulus black a member of
the Noble House of black was Sirius
Black's brother in my opinion his
absence from the films was one of their
biggest mistakes regulus is portrayed as
a former deater who later became
disillusioned with the ideology and
actions of Voldemort's followers he made
attempts to sabotage the Dark Lord's
plans and even managed to steal one of
Voldemort's HW cruxes later sacrificing
his life to destroy it his incredible
sacrifice and determination to write his
wrongs showcased the theme of redemption
that resonated throughout the series
despite the importance of his character
in the books regulus black didn't make
an appearance in the Harry Potter film
leaving viewers unaware of his integral
role in the fight against Voldemort
Hestia Jones is a minor character in the
Harry Potter series who becomes a member
of the Order of the Phoenix she is
described as a kind and loyal witch who
shows unwavering support for Harry and
his friends in their fight against
Voldemort serving in the advanced guard
and helping to escort the deres from
their home to a safe location panelope
Clearwater was a Ravenclaw student first
introduced as Percy Weasley's girlfriend
in Harry Potter in the Chamber of
Secrets while at Hogwarts she becomes a
victim of the Basilisk attacks along
with herione when the pair attempt to
use Penelope's mirror to take a look at
it by removing Penelope we lost a bit of
a sense of how impactful the basilisk's
presence was on the student body
furthermore her removal men at Percy had
no love interest in the series wilky Twi
cross was a Ministry of magic employee
and Apparition instructor he appeared in
Harry Potter and the halfblood prince
during the students Apparition lessons
although his appearance was brief the
removal of wilk's character resulted in
a missed opportunity to explore the
intricacies of apparition and its
significance in The Wizarding World
Professor tofy was an examiner for The
Wizarding examinations Authority his
presence during the students written owl
exams in Harry Potter and the old of the
Phoenix added tension and pressure to an
already stressful period for the
characters unlike many others on this
list tof's Omission went by fairly
unnoticed Florian forcu was the owner of
an ice cream parlor in D alley and a
minor character in Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of aaban Florine was known for
helping Harry out with his homework
Harry didn't have to do his homework
under the blankets by flashlight anymore
now he could sit in the bright sunshine
outside Florian for's ice cream parlor
finishing all his essays with occasional
help from floran forcu himself who apart
from knowing a great deal about medieval
witch burnings gave Harry free Sundays
every half an hour Bera jorkins was a
witch and a minor character introduced
in Harry Potter and the godber of fire
she was an employee at the ministry of
magic who became an unwitting victim of
FL Voldemort's rise to power you see
Bera was the one that Voldemort killed
to turn Nini into one of his Haw ruxers
it seems odd that Bera was omitted given
her close affiliation with one of the
driving aspects of the story monu is a
supporting character in the Harry Potter
series who is a member of souin House
and serves on the Souther in Quidditch
team as a chaser monu becomes involved
in a crucial moment in the books when he
is forcibly shoved into a Vanishing
cabinet by Fred and George Weasley
however monu's appearance were limited
and he did not feature in the films
leaving out an opportunity to delve
deeper into the Dynamics of Hogwart
students during this tense period
sturgus podmore was a member of the
Order of the Phoenix and a loyal Ally in
the fight against vort serving as one of
the advanced guard podmore was notably
put under the imperious curse by death
heaters and made to attempt to break
into the department of mysteries a crime
for which he was sentenced to 6 months
in aaban emilene vance was a
well-respected witch and a member of the
Order of the Phoenix who was a member
for both the first and second visiting
Wars she was a part of the advanced
guard and although her character had
limited appearances in the books her
role represented the diverse talents and
contributions made by order members
emiline was murdered when she was
attacked by Death Eaters near the
residence of the Muggle prime minister
in the second week of July 1996
rodolphus lrange was a death heater and
a loyal servant of Lord Voldemort but
perhaps most importantly he was the
husband of Bellatrix the strange
rodolphus and his wife Bellatrix are
notorious for their unwavering support
for Voldemort and their involvement in
his reign of terror while rodolphus does
not receive much individual development
in the series his character embodies the
cruelty and fanaticism of Voldemort's
followers he participates in several
dark arts including including the
torture of Frank and Dallas Longbottom
which ultimately leads to their Insanity
his absence from the films diminished
the exploration of the ill estrange
family and their connection to Voldemort
depriving viewers of a deeper
understanding of the dark side of the
Wizarding World the Muggle prime
minister was a character introduced in
Harry Potter and the Half Bud Prince he
represented the Muggle side of the
wisting Muggle relations the Muggle
prime minister's interactions with the
ad minist of magic provided insight into
the challenges and complexities of
Bridging the magical and non-magical
worlds his inclusion in the films would
have brought an additional layer of
depth to the story and emphasized the
importance of understanding and
cooperation between magical and
non-magical communities Ronan was a
member of the Centaur herd in the
Forbidden Forest at Hogwarts he's
portrayed as wise and knowledgeable but
also somewhat aloof and skeptical of of
human Affairs showcasing a general
distrust for humankind despite all of
this however he did try to protect Harry
Potter and herione Granger from the
other centur in
1996 pointing out that they were Falls
during the Skirmish in the Forbidden
Forest involving Dolores Umbridge Madame
Malin was the proprietor of Madame
malin's robes for All Occasions a
well-known robe shop in Diagon Alle in
the books she played a minor yet
important role in Harry's Journey often
equipping him and his friends with their
Hogwarts robes however Madame malin's
character did not make it into the films
which meant viewers missed out on the
interactions and the Lively atmosphere
of her sharp her inclusion in the films
would have enhanced the worldbuilding
aspect of Diagon Al and allowed viewers
to immerse themselves further in a
magical shopping experience brck bod
notably worked as an unspeakable in the
department of mysteries he's described
as having sow skin and a mournful face
in the events of Harry Potter and the
Order of the Phoenix bod is imperious by
Lucius Malfoy under Voldemort's orders
causing him to lose the power of speech
and believe he's a teapot as a result
bod becomes a long-term resident in the
Janus thicky Ward at St Mongo's hospital
and that concludes the definitive list
of characters who aren't shown at all I
should mention however that there are
some characters who despite not having
any lines are shown in the background
because they technically are in the
films I decided not to include them
examples include Madame Prince and
professors such as Septima vecta and
Aurora sinistra there's always the
possibility that I've missed someone so
please do let me know down in the
comment section below if there's someone
that needs to be included again if they
were shown in any capacity then they
were omitted from this particular list
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to
[Music]
live